yo this I feel like I'm watching it like
it's very much like you see in an action
scene and I can see you okay but I feel
like oh maybe she she might be like a
music student maybe she went to
juilliards or
um this is accurate I only heard this
song before I'm saying that because I've
heard this song before she'll be at the
club like literally lyric for lyric
singing I mean I like that I think this
is that type of person I feel like very
bubbly she has a lot of energy oh maybe
she drinks like Boba Gary
the all pop songs I guess like I have an
idea that there may be a design student
or like an artsy student right but I
feel like people listen to public more
generalized but at the same time I think
she realizes that that's not what she
wants to do forever either she's making
that bag and then getting ready to make
moves the fact that they just listened
to a few songs yeah and they can like
understand my life story she is trying
to spread her wings or she wants to
spread her wings oh I love that